-Welcome back to "Late Night"
on Thanksgiving.
My family is here.
But, Dad, Albert
has come in from outside.
-Yeah. He wants to be part
of the program.
-That's great. Now, is that --
Is he --
He's in your marital bed
right now. Correct?
-He's in our bed.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Will he sleep
in the bed tonight?
-He'll sleep in the bed
for a little while.
Then he'll get on the floor.
But he will --
He comes in bed
in the morning about
20, 30 minutes before it's time
to get up and gets between
the two of us
and he'll go back to sleep.
And then until I roll over
and wake up
and then I get this tremendous
affection to start my day.
I wake up in the best mood.
[ Laughter ]
I get a thousand kisses.
I got a lot of nuzzles.
-Is that a thousand when you add
up his kisses and Mom's
or is that all Albert?
-It's a thousand.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, so it's now time
for a Thanksgiving tradition
that is now seven years running,
which started when my firstborn,
Ashe.
We dressed him up
as a turkey one year
and then we dressed
him up as a turkey again.
And then we dressed up him
and his brother Axel.
Last year we added
our daughter Adelaide,
and I'm always worried the boys
are going to say,
"We don't want to dress up
like turkeys again.
You know, we're not your clowns
to perform at your whim."
But they were very enthusiastic
about being turkeys again.
So here it is, year seven of
the Meyers kids as turkeys.
-Happy Thanksgiving!
Da-da, happy Thanksgiving!
[ Audience aws ]
Fly. I can fly. I can fly.
I can fly. I can fly.
[ Laughter ]
-Happy birthday.
-Happy Thanksgiving!
-Eee-goo-goo!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very nice.
-Not bad.
-They did a very, very good job.
And it should be noted.
I think they all enjoy it
except for Frisbee,
who hates it more
than anything in the world.
-Yeah.
-It turns out most dogs
do not value the tradition
of Thanksgiving,
nor do they want
to dress like pilgrims.
-And I don't think she hates it
more as it progresses.
I think she's always hated it
exactly as much.
-She's always hated it the most
a dog could hate it.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
Thanksgiving is obviously a time
to spend with family.
But I also want to talk about
those who are no longer with us.
Your sister Sherry
passed away this year.
And I want to just tell
a couple of my favorite stories
about Sherry,
who was a wonderful aunt
and a wonderful person.
Now, this is a photo
when you and your sisters
came to the show, and there
you are sitting in a row.
You might see thematically
they kind of look alike.
This is Sherry there.
And we refer to you
and your sisters as the geese.
-Yes.
-Because when you are walking in
the street or down a hallway,
it feels like a flock of birds.
-Yes. And they're very loud too.
-Yes, they're very loud.
They make some noise.
But when you were here,
I cut to you guys.
I mentioned the geese.
And it turned out
that resonated with some people.
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, and you also made a comment
about how we were all different
samples of Benjamin Moore
paint, the color of our --
-It looks like one paint strip
of Benjamin Moore paint.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I had gotten them tickets
to -- we went to see "Hamilton,"
the four of us.
And pretty close
to Hamilton was
Don't Call --
Don't Tell Mama, a bar.
So we were going
to go there afterwards.
So we're walking across
the street and a busy street,
and somebody stops us and says,
"Wait a minute,
are you the geese?"
[ Laughter ]
And my sister Sherry says,
"Yes, we certainly are."
So then, like another block,
the exact same thing happens.
"Are you the geese?"
She was so thrilled.
So thrilled. And then we get to
Don't Tell Mama.
-Yeah, I got there early
to reserve a table.
Don't Tell Mama is a great bar.
The staff sing show tunes.
It's very active, very lively.
It's a great time.
And so, you know,
the staff is singing
and walking around
and everyone's into it.
And Sherry just has her head
down on the table with a pen
and cocktail napkins.
And I was like, "Sherry,
what are you doing?"
And she's like,
"Well, we're famous now.
So I'm signing napkins so I can
have something to sell."
And I was like, "What are you
going to sell them for?"
And she thinks for a minute
and she writes $10 on one.
And on another one,
she's like $5.
I was like, "What's
the difference?"
She's like,
"How bad do they want it?
[ Laughter ]
-Late in life,
she had her moment of fame
and she took
great financial advantage.
-Yes.
-My favorite Sherry story is
we went -- I took you and all
your sisters to see "Les Mis."
-Yes.
-And we were up in the balcony.
-Way, way up.
-Way up in the balcony.
-Vertiginous walk.
-Not great seats.
And a vertiginous walk
is a very, very well-put
way of saying it.
And Sherry was not
the most mobile of aunts.
-No.
-And she also --
Would you say she wore the most
jewelry anyone's ever worn?
-I would say there were
30 bracelets on each arm.
-Yeah.
-At least two rings per finger.
But the bracelets
were mostly jangly bracelets.
And my sister Alex
would take her on trips.
And when they get
to the TSA thing,
Alex would just
throw up her hands.
She said, "She can't
take them off.
You need to get a locksmith
because they can't --"
And she couldn't.
She never took them off.
She slept in them.
So it was jangle, jangle.
-When she walked,
I remember saying that
it was like Jacob Marley
in "A Christmas Carol."
-Yes.
-Like, just the jangling
chains of a vengeful ghost.
-Yes.
-And so she had
to go to the bathroom
in the middle of "Les Mis,"
and I was already like --
middle of the aisle,
vertiginous.
She gets up, jingles down.
-Well, my sister Christy went
with her.
-Yes.
-And she asked Christy first,
who always has this
huge pocketbook with her.
"Do you happen to have
a flashlight in there
to get us to the bathroom?"
-And I remember at the time
going like,
"Nobody has a flashlight."
-So she roots through.
She said, "Dinner roll,
lip balm, wrench. Wait.
Oh, I found a pad of butter."
I'm not kidding you.
This is what she has
in her purse.
And then she locates
a flashlight.
She says, "We're in luck."
So it's a little pen thing.
So the two of them take off
and very slow progress.
-Yeah.
-And all of a sudden --
-Slow and loud.
-Yeah.
Crazy loud. Jingle jangle.
-So all of a sudden, a door --
The theater is flooded in light.
They've opened the door
to the outside.
They thought it
was the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
The sun's pouring in.
-Yeah, just these
two nutty aunts
silhouetted by the daytime sun
as they go out on the fire
escape looking for the bathroom.
-And this one --
This one grabs my hand and says,
"For the love of God, Mother,
do something."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "What? What can I do?"
-So I had to run over
and grab -- wrangle
my aunts back to their seats.
-Yeah.
-But it was a lovely story.
It was one
that was often retold.
And I am very thankful for
all our time with Sherry.
-Exactly.
-She will be missed.
-Rest in peace.
So here we are.
Dad, are you good?
Are you excited
that you're testing negative
and you're going
to be able to see us?
-Yeah. Really excited.
Really looking forward to it.
-Alright, good.
[ Laughter ]
-I just have to leave Albert.
That's the downside.
-Yeah. Well, you guys, thank you
for being with us.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."